brandon is with us in phoenix arizona
good afternoon brandon how can cain and
i help
hey thank you guys for taking my call so
i wanted to kind of just run by my
current
situation with you and get your opinion
uh
i'm 21 i'm on baby step two i have about
3 000 on my card note and just about the
same
on my student loans um
i have an issue with spending money on
buying stuff i don't need
i convince myself like from i want it to
i need it
and i need it now and so i decided to go
all in with this program and i basically
just want to
you know i want to get out of debt i
don't want to go back in so how do i
how do i fight that urge and not go back
into debt after paying off my
my loans oh man um good question
how much money do you make right now a
year brandon
uh about 30 to 34
000 depending on like overtime and stuff
like that
cool are you living at home with your
parents so you have your own place
uh i'm with my grandfather okay all
right with your grandfather
all right cool um so your question today
is how do i hold myself accountable
to the plan and do not overspend money
but take control of my financial future
right
right okay ken my answer is very quick
yeah well i want to hear it what was
your my answer
yeah um just do it
i don't really think there's motivation
you know it's a choice
you know brandon i think the key thing
that you have to tell yourself is
do it i'm not going to do this i'm not
going to go here
i'm not going to purchase this i'm going
to do it
because you're six thousand dollars in
debt you make 34 000
a year you're staying at home with your
grandparents i'm so
i am assuming that you're not paying
them any rent correct
uh no i do pay my part of the bill like
the gas electric and stuff like that
though
so that's about 150 a month correct
uh about yeah like 150 175 how much do
you have in your savings account
uh my savings is about 1100
and i got about 900 in my checking okay
all right so
here's what you got to do man um you
gotta attack
you gotta attack your debt 6k living at
home only paying 150
a month on just to go towards your bills
you should be out of debt within the
next two and a half months by january
15th
you should be 100 debt free you know
especially when it comes to young people
you know i i try to be very careful with
what i say with my words
because i remember being your age and
telling myself i can't do this i can't
i have a problem with this well if i
know i have a problem which i want to
commend you on and acknowledging you
have a problem
if you can acknowledge it you can change
it and so
for me i'm going to say bro just you
know the plan
you know how to work the plan just do it
look at you look yourself in the mirror
and say you know what i have this
problem but today it ends
and tomorrow i'm going to become a new
man and i'm going to take control of my
finances in my future
all right brandon here we go you ready
yeah
your problem is you've been spending to
feel good
instead of acting to be good and you're
all about the feeling when you spend
like this
i'm not going to try to psychoanalyze
you you can tell me if i'm wrong by the
way
right now i have no problem admitting
that i'm wrong
on the third largest radio show in the
world but
my guess is i'm right that when you're
spending like this when someone
says i'm having a hard time because i
buy things that i really don't need
we're trying to fill some type of a hole
with that purchase and really it comes
down to whatever the reason for the hole
is we're trying to make ourselves
feel good and i think that you've got to
acknowledge that maybe even get some
help on that
it may be not that deep of an issue it
may just be where your focus is and
that's why i started with focusing on
feeling good versus focusing on
being good and what i want you to do is
think of that desired future
what's that dream 5 10 15 years from now
where do you want to be
what's the big picture what's the story
you want people to tell
about your life and every time you make
a boneheaded purchase
you are pressing pause on that desired
future do you understand what i'm saying
yeah yeah i do am i right or am i wrong
about your
feeling trying to feel good with these
purchases
no you're you're completely right i
didn't have much anything growing up
and so now that i'm able to get stuff i
just feel like i have to have it now or
i'm not going to have it later all right
so let me talk to you let me talk to you
here's what's going on you come from a
very tough background you didn't have
much
and now that you're out on your own
you're trying to prove to yourself that
you're not your parents am i really
stepping on the nerve right now
yeah that's correct come on man i feel
you
you're trying to create a
you're you're you're dealing with a
false narrative
that's saying that brandon is who his
parents were and so you're trying to
prove to yourself
and everybody else that you're not who
your parents were that you have
something
that you are somebody and i can tell you
my friend
you are somebody regardless of how many
things you have and how many zeros you
have in your bank account do you hear me
yes so you need to shift your focus to
what your desired future is
and how the finances allow you to make
that future happen if you change your
focus
to the story that you are telling with
your life
and not trying to show everybody that
you're not who your mom and dad
are or were then i think you're going to
see behavior change that would be my
take
i like it man here's another thing too
brandon is
um you know you and i probably grew up
right around the same
type of uh family growing up
one of the key things that i've learned
is
i had a lot growing up for my parents i
didn't i didn't have a lot of practical
things but my parents taught me a lot
one of the key things that made me spend
like you when i was your age
wasn't because i didn't have but because
of what i was seeing around me
and so one thing i would even suggest
that you do is on top of the change
on top of changing your own narrative
maybe for a while
watch what you're putting inside of your
eyes you know watch what you're seeing
on social media
watch what you're hearing in the music
like change uh
what you are exposing yourself to
because whatever you expose yourself to
then you want to become that and you
really have to get comfortable with your
own life
with where you are in life what you can
do in life
because i think sometimes it's not about
really just our past that plays a huge
role
but sometimes it's about what we see
you're right other people do come on
let's
especially with with young people that's
really really good yes and amen to my
bro
right here on this and i'm going to add
something to that
i'm sick and tired and i could throw out
names but then i'd
then then i'd have to talk to james and
kelly about it and then i'd you know
whatever
yeah there are a lot of social media
influencers that are in the personal
development space that we are in
yeah and i look at their instagram posts
and they're selling a lie
and they're helping create the crap that
brandon is dealing with you told
you know why they're going success is a
boat success is being in debt
and having three or four real estate
properties success is having all this
bling
man success is having all this stuff and
they're
creating this comparison cancer
for people and social media is
crushing people's actual dreams
because they're too busy looking at what
everybody else says is success
and they're not paying attention to what
their definition of success is
you got to watch it ao is right you got
to stop hanging out on those instagram
accounts with all these people
lying to you with their flashy life i'm
going to tell you something
they're an absolute mess and they're
profiting
off of comparison oh i'm fired up and
here's the thing
i know exactly who you're talking about
yeah i think america knows exactly i
really
want to say this one dude's name if dave
was here he would say
he calls dave out he calls david calls
dave
out and dave is such a gentleman yes he
ain't even gonna play that game
but i'm telling you right now there's a
dude who's telling people that dave is
wrong
and that you need all the debt you can
possibly stack up
so you can live the lavish like no don't
say it because i don't wanna i'm telling
we're
he's wrong that's all i'm saying he's
absolutely wrong and he's profiteering
off of a comparison game which is
dangerous there it is that's all i'm
saying